just sort of there's a saying and I
don't remember who says whose quote this
is but it's basically that
um instead of trying to fix fix an
existing system just create a new one so
like is it even fixable or is it just
create a new one and start a commune
like I've been talking about for five
years we've probably actually end up in
the same thing because the commune will
get popular it'll be super fun and
everybody will be having a great time
and then all of a sudden there'll be too
many people and then we're like well we
kind of need someone in charge with the
stick you know like yeah I'm in charge
I'm talking and then all of a sudden
you're probably gonna have to have like
a secretary and because there's gonna be
bills and you have to redo roads and
stuff and then all of a sudden we're
going to end up in the same place again
probably but the commune would work for
a while I think I've had the exact same
thought actually really my country would
be called kazstan I've already thought
of that but then I'm like then we'd run
into the same
you know and I'd be like Kazan you do
what you want you take care of you but
then you know again like you said I
probably couldn't handle it all by
myself and I don't want to I don't want
to get into politics because I don't
want to make decisions for other people
I don't understand how
you would want it like people would want
to go into that I just kind of want to
be left alone and leave other people
Alone
um but when it comes to speech stuff you
have to just I mean for me I've always
just decided I'm going to try to lead by
example and that's the reason why I
wrote the book the way I did
um a friend of mine who works here's
names Guy Benson he has a radio show
here interviewed me and he had an
advanced copy and he said as I was
reading it I was like she she really
just shared that like did she really
just you know make that joke about her
you know her mom dying like her
experience with her mom dying or her
medical emergencies or and it's yes I
did because I want to prove that by
example I want to show that actually yes
you can joke about everything and if I
was going to write this book and say
that then I had to actually prove that I
meant it because you know the end result
is that I found all of it healing I
found humor healing through all these
traumatic experiences and the other
thing that you need to do and the other
part of living by example is to also be
measured in your response to jokes that
you don't like or to someone saying
something that maybe even offends you
because
I know everybody says like facts don't
care about your feelings and that's true
but also feelings don't care about your
facts sometimes like humans are
emotional creatures I'm a very emotional
person I'm very sensitive but there's a
difference between being sensitive and
expecting the whole world really to
revolve around your own sensitivity
that's just being selfish so I think
that being measured in your criticism if
someone says something you don't like
you can say you know that hurt my
feelings that's different than demanding
that they be fired or something you know
this or that and I think we need to
weigh in tension more someone was just
trying to make a joke that is different
than someone who is trying to be a jerk
right exactly if somebody uses like a
derogatory term as slang versus like
because it's just kind of particulture
versus something that is it
intentionally meant to make you feel
horrible that's right or how about just
like uh that guy over there and like you
know we're having a crisis moment in
culture of like being able to call
someone girl or a boy right now and like
what if it what if you you don't mean
anything buy it right you're just like
trying to like use a reference it's
really just a guide to like bring
attention oh that person over there like
I don't know I totally agree with you
like I've said this even in
relationships
if something doesn't seem right just
know my intention like my intention is
like I'm not trying to hurt you right
I'm not trying to make you feel bad what
what is the like
I don't know I I think identity politics
is a huge problem right now
yeah I do think it is because I think
that also the people who claim to be the
huge activists for this they don't
they're actually not doing themselves
any favors I mean when it comes to
speech historically I mean from like the
Civil Rights Movement to gay rights
movement to you know Susan B Anthony all
that historically have been very
pro-free speech and pro First Amendment
because they understand that groups that
are fighting for things that might be
marginalized are the ones that need free
speech the most and also let's say like
going back to the trans thing let's say
your main issue the thing that you care
about the most in the world is trans
activism and the last thing you want to
do is treat somebody who for example
does what you did and acts you know
maybe accidentally says something that
hurts somebody's feelings and be like
okay that's it you're a transpho because
then people are going to stop asking
questions and there's not like there's a
very small percentage of people that are
trans so a lot of people have never met
a trans person in their entire life so
if you really want people to understand
your cause and understand people and you
have to be open to having people talk
about it without being afraid to talk
about it that's so true while there's a
healthy amount of awareness that could
be created yes I think there's a dark
side of people wanting to have an excuse
and be to be a victim
I absolutely think that that has to be
the case right because I mean there's
really I mean I I there's this new idea
that like I'm white and someone else is
black then that means that like I
there's nothing that I can say that
could be relatable to that person which
is crazy because I don't know what it's
like to be a black person obviously but
that doesn't mean that as humans that we
would have nothing in common and there's
this idea now even with jokes that if it
draws on you know an experience of a
woman meaning a biological woman who's
born woman is still a woman then that
somehow excludes trans people just
because it's not about you doesn't mean
it excludes you it's just not about you
and it's it does apply to a lot of
people and there should be you know an
outlet because there are unique things
that come with being a biological woman
like you have a period and you know you
worry about different things than
biological men do that's not excluding
anybody because you can also then use
your own voice to share your own
experience and what we've done now is
like you said maybe like even talking
about black artistic people like then
they just don't talk about race at all
or you're like afraid like that's not a
good thing either that's the last thing
people should want and especially when
it comes to jokes when people
are trying to make a joke they're trying
to make people laugh so the intention
there is good and especially with comedy
the only way to know if a joke works or
not is to try it because there's been
times so dangerous it is Contracting as
hell it's you can't tell I mean it's
part of doing it's I mean I I've done
stand up on and off I'm not really doing
it right now kind of doing live shows
that I'm getting back into that are like
half stand up so I'll probably get back
there again because it's hard to quit
once you've done it but you don't know
you can think something's so funny in
your head and then you go on stage and
you're like oh that didn't work and now
the penalty for that is like your whole
career is over and yeah right you don't
cancel because you don't know how it's
going to come off or are people going to
receive it because we're all different
and if we make people too afraid to try
and what's going to happen is let's say
you don't like this one joke you'll be
like like I was saying are you like okay
that it hurt my feelings and leave it at
that
but you have to keep in mind that you
have to be measured in your response
because you might be making other people
afraid to make other jokes that might be
about subjects that really resonate with
you that you might need during a
difficult time in your life sure I mean
I I agree with you you said a few
minutes ago you said that he you know
humor is is healing and I think a big
aspect of the healing from my
perspective is that you start talking
about it you just get it out there which
is why it's so good that your book is
about talking about stuff you're not
supposed to talk about because no matter
what it is when we don't get it out and
we suppress it that sticks in the body
and becomes disease that becomes
um a projection when someone makes a
comment or does something because you've
got something sticky in there and when
you just joke about it you just you get
it out and you start clearing the air
and we can all we can all laugh and you
can and you it's like a form of
processing it and so like I feel like
the last Mohicans are comedians to being
able to you're like the last line of
defense to being able to say
I'm gonna say just about everything
yeah and I mean if you treat something
as oh so sacred and oh so untouchable
that gives it more power over you you
know and by laughing in its face that's
takes the power away I first started
doing stand-up I mean I talk about this
in my first chapter where I was living
in La things were not going well I was
very broke uh I lived in like this
horrible apartment where I slept on a
yoga mat then I lost the apartment and I
was living with this bartender that I
was like sort of seeing from my
waitressing job but not really and you
know I'd explain to him like we're not
really together because I need to live
here
like 22 years old I didn't know anybody
the only people I knew were like my cat
that's still alive and then my you know
ex-boyfriend who had broken up with me
and so I started getting on stage and
telling jokes about this stuff and it
wasn't that this stuff was funny right
but I was able to poke fun at it which
gave me I felt totally powerless the
rest of the time that was the one time
like I felt like I had some power and
then hearing other people laugh was my
only means of connection through that
time I believe in energy a lot and so
like just the the positive energy and
frequency of laughing is so beneficial
to the body that you know I it does not
Shock me that there are stats out there
that humor
um can be even more beneficial than
medicine yeah and making and they say it
makes people feel better so I think
that's another one because people like
oh but you don't mean illness I'm like
no I do and like you don't mean death
I'm like no I mean I yes I do and
um it's been really healing the first
time I ever talked about the bag
publicly was when the book came out so a
lot of people at work like realize they
were on TV with me during that time and
they had no idea but it is really
healing and that's my last chapter I
write about how comedy is actually a
sort of religion for me because it has a
lot of the same healing properties as
you know physically but also emotionally
as religion does and the way it can add
meaning to experiences because and I
write in the book about all these things
that almost destroyed me and I was able
to actually create from those things if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen